قبل عقدين من الزمن تغير المشهد في العراق
راسا على عقب بعد قرار الولايات المتحده
شن حرب على العراق وهو ما تبنته بريطانيا
بحجه وجود اسلحه دمار شامل بحوزه النظام
العراقي الذي كان على راسه رئيس الاسباق
صدام حسين ليله التاسع عشر من اذار عام
2003 اطلق الرئيس الامريكي انذاك جورج w
بوش حمله اطاحه صدام التي اطلق عليها
الصدمه والترويع بقصف عنيف استهدف بغداد
في محاوله لقتل صدام حسين وهو ما لم يتحقق
لتنطلق الحرب البريه
160 الف جندي امريكي ارسل حينها الى ارض
العراق ولم تدم الحرب طويلا ومع بدايه اي
بريل انهار جيش صدام ودخل الامريكيون
العاصمه العراقيه بدوره كشف بول برايمر
المبعوثه الرئاسي الامريكي السابق الى
العراق تفاصيل بالغه الاهميه للشرق الاوسط
معترفا بارتكابه خطا ومؤكدا انه حتى لو
عاد بهم الزمن 20 عاما الى الوراء فان
التحرك نحو الاطاحه بالرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين كان قرارا صائما
حكم العراق لاكثر من عام بصفته رئيسا
لسلطه الائتلاف المؤقته بول بريمر حملوا
اسرار العراق لعقدين من الزمن يعترف
لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط بارتكاب خطاين
رئيسيين ضمن المهمه التي اصدر خلالها مئه
من المراسيم اولها اجتهاث تفكيك البعث
والثاني حل الجيش العراقي
لكنه بالرغم من ذلك اصر على صوابيه قرار
الحرب وضروره الاطاحه بصدام حسين
وبحسب بريمير مهما كان وضع العراق فانه
يبقى افضل حالا بعد عشرين عاما برحيل صدام
مضيفا انه لو بقي صدام في السلطه
لاصبح العالم امام قوتين نوويتين على
الاقل هما ايران والعراق